hi I'm Chet Haase an engineer on the
Android team at Google so I saw a talk
recently at Google i/o where they were
showing some example animation code
which I always liked and I saw something
curious there which was someone said
well we need to animate a couple of
properties at the same time on the same
target object and we can't do that
directly with object animator so we're
going to use the value animator object
and do it more manually and I thought
hmm that's not actually correct so I
wanted to so I realized at that point I
thought this was obvious how to do this
and I realized maybe it would be good if
I actually explained to how to do this
in general there's a there's a class
called property values holder that you
might want to know about if you need to
do this on your own targets and
properties so I have a demo to show you
here with four simple buttons on it all
of which want to be animated and you'll
notice that all of them animate
remarkably similarly in fact it's
effectively the same animation happening
on all of them but the code for doing it
is very different so for the first
button we use a value animator animation
and this is the example that I saw in
this particular talk said okay we're
going to use value animator and this
will return a value between 0 and 1 and
then we take this value and we figure
out what the values what the target
value should be on the target object
that we're trying to animate so I do
that here so the approach to doing this
with a value animator is you create your
value animator between start and end
values here it doesn't actually matter
what those values are because we're
going to be using the animated fraction
anyway and then we add an update
listener so that we get a call back on
every single animation frame and then
during that frame we get the animated
fraction this gives us a value between 0
& 1 to tell us where in the course of
this animation the animation is and then
we can take that value and use it to
interpolate the value of our our end
targets and end properties so here we
simply set the translation X and the
translation Y values directly on the
object with a simple linear
interpolation and then we start the
animation very straightforward but there
are easier ways to do this
with a lot less code the second one is
probably the easiest way to do this an
important point to note here is I would
always use view property animator in
this particular situation right I'm
animating properties on a view
translation X and translation Y and this
is exactly why view property animator
was created the code is very simple and
streamlined you can do things in
parallel and the same animation and it's
it's very efficient at animating
multiple things because it has intrinsic
knowledge about views that make its
invalidation and rendering an update
system very efficient internally so it's
the right thing to use but sometimes
you're animating things that aren't
simply properties on a view in which
case you couldn't use you a property
animator and you'll need to use one of
the techniques that I show a little bit
later so if you can use view property
animator here's how it would work you
would call animate on the view that
returns a view property animator object
and then we say translation X to the N
value translation Y to the N value and
you're done don't need to call start
don't need to do these in separate
statements you're basically just
building up the animation and when
you're done building it it automatically
starts in the next frame and you're good
to go
straightforward easy to use use for your
property animator but if you can't maybe
you're looking at using object animators
instead so this is what's the example
that I saw was trying to avoid was
creating multiple object animators even
though you're only animating one object
we all know that creating more and more
objects especially during animations may
be a bad thing so maybe you want to
avoid this but it's it's fairly
straightforward this is maybe the the
trivial approach to solving this problem
with an object animator which is I want
one object animator that animates the
values for translation X I want another
object animator that animates the values
for translation Y and I want you to
start both of them pretty simple if you
need to choreograph it a little more
carefully you can use an animator set
add these things into play sequentially
or play together or play with other
animators all very straightforward not a
big deal but you are creating a couple
of object animators that are sort of
running without knowledge of each other
and maybe that's just not as efficient
at what
you really wanted to do what you really
wanted to do was the following you want
to use property values holders this is
actually what object animator uses
internally but you can access it on the
outside too in this case we're animating
the same object but we're animating
multiple properties on the same object
in parallel so what we're going to do is
set up a property's value holder to
animate our translation X property to
the end value another property values
holder to animate the translation Y
property on the same object and then
we're going to set up the object
animator and this is what associates the
property values holders with the actual
target object of our view so now that
we've set up property values holder
would come down here and we create a
single object animator and we say okay
on our target view I want you to use
this property value holder for
translation X the other property values
holder for translation Y and I want you
to start it and bang you're done so
animating multiple properties in
parallel on the same target object view
property animator if you can use it
property values holder if you can't
thanks